I think that it's easier sort of
narrative and it's a more comfortable
narrative to push that there was this
that southerners or southern states were
just pushing for for more rights as
states and and it's a deeply American
narrative because obviously the United
States is a federation of states and
each states has its own set of policies
and then you have a national government
with its own set of policy so it seems
sort of inherent in the American story
but northern states historically have
advocated policies that have been
challenged by federal power and so this
is this is a national issue in terms of
the relationship between states and the
federal government but what wasn't a
national issue were the rights of
slaveholders right were the rights of
segregationist and the ways in which
they felt at times that the federal
government was not supporting them by
allowing them to continue to spread
throughout the United States in terms of
slaveholders and and and and obviously
enslaved people each of these books did
not talk about the role that white
supremacy played in the ideology of the
Confederate States of America and so
that's how I think people today could be
like well what's wrong with the
Confederacy they were just advocating
for states rights they were just
advocating for freedom against Northern
Aggression those who were enslaved I
think so and I think so to give an
example the vice president of the
Confederacy Alexander Stephens in 1862
gave what became known as the
cornerstone speech which to me if
there's a speech that really speaks to
the principles and the ideology of the
Confederate States of America it's this
speech this speech wasn't quoted in any
of these books in that speech he stated
that the Confederacy is founded on the
great truth that the Negro is not equal
to the white man and slavery
subordination to the superior race is
is natural and normal condition so again
I think what if we use the term slavery
and slave holders rights as opposed to
states rights part of the problem with
the term states rights is that this was
the term that the Confederate states
that later segregationist and even some
slaveholders utilized to hide that they
were really fighting for the rights of
slaveholders